Selamlar R tayfam. 9. sınıf tayfam.
Keyifler nasıl bakalım? İnşallah
keyiflerimiz yerindedir. Her şey
yolundadır diyelim. Yolumuza devam
edelim. 3. modülde sayfa 32'de kaldık ve
yeni bir başlık atıyoruz. Artık önemli
bir başlık aslında. Söyleyeyim mi ben
sana? Şimdi başlığımız şu: Eşlik ve
benzerlik. Ama eşlik ve benzerliğe
girmeden önce MAP müfredatı diyor ki
kardeşim diyor ben de bulursam inşallah
sayfayı göstereceğim sana. Sayfayı
bulamıyorum. Demek ki 32 sayfa değilmiş
ya. Ben 32. sayfa diye şey yaptım ama
sayfa 39'muş pardon. Sayfa 39'u
açıyorsun. Geometrik dönüşümlere
gireceğiz. Öncesinde şöyle 3 sayfalık
bir şey işleyeceğiz. Sonrasında artık
eşlik benzerlik olayına üçgenlerde
geleceğiz. Ha geçen sene buradan bir
tane soru geldi. Yine gelebilir. O
yüzden dikkatli olmalıyız. Tamam mı? Ne
var ne yok. Ben en ince detayı ne kadar
sana anlatacağım. Hiç merak etme.
Ördekleri çözeceğim. Mis gibi bu konuyu
da bitireceğiz. Gönder gelsin diyorum.
Ama tekrar bir hatırlatma yapayım. Bazı
arkadaşlar hala soruyorlar. Hocam
PDF'ler nerede? Ya da ders çalışma
şeyleri, modülleri falan nerede?
ww.rehbermatematik.com
rehbermatematik.com sitemizin nihayet
yapay zeka desteği ile tek tek satır
satır kodlayarak açtık arkadaşlar.
Tayfalar bölümüne giriyorsun ya da
mobilde kullanıyorsan kamplar bölümüne
de tıklayabilirsin. 9. sınıfa
tıklıyorsun. Dersini buluyorsun. Hop
buradan indiriyorsun. Ama arenaya
hepinizi bekliyorum. Birçok arkadaş
gelmeye başladı. Ben bugün şimdilik 9
yayın ama belki yükselebilirim. Burada
da Marif Modele özel bilgi yarışmamız
var. Mutlaka oraya gelmeni isterim.
Hatta Marif Model denemesi var. Blog
sayfası var. Buraları biraz dolaş. Emrin
faydalı içerik bulacaksın orada kendine.
Şimdi mevzuya gel bakalım. Mevzu ne?
Geometrik dönüşümler. Hocam nedir bu
geometrik dönüşümler? Düzlemde bir şekli
hareket ettirme amaçlı geometrik
dönüşümlerden faydalanılır. Bu
dönüşümler yardımıyla mevcut şekildeki
noktalar başka bir şekille birebir
eşlenir ve yeni eş şekiller elde edilir.
Bak burada eş şekiller elde edeceğiz. Bu
dönüşümler nelerdir hocam diye bana
sorarsan yansıma, öteleme ve dönme
dönüşümlerine bakacağız. Bu üçünü
öğreneceğiz. Sonra üçgenlerdeki eşitlik
benzerlik mevzusuna gideceğiz. Peki
yansıma dönüşüm ve özellikleri nelerdir
hocam? Düzlemde bir geometrik şeklin bir
doğruya göre yansıma dönüşümü bulunurken
geometrik şeklin tüm noktaları verilen
doğruya göre simetrisi. Şimdi bak
simetri kelimesi burada yansıma
kelimesiyle aynı anlama gelir. Bazen
sorularda der ki bu noktanın işte bu
doğruya göre yansımasını, bu noktanın bu
doğruya göre simetrisini, bu şeklin bu
doğruya göre yansıması ya da simetrisini
diye sorar. Hiç merak etme hepsi aynı
anlama gelecek. alınarak yeni şeklin
noktaları belirlenir. Bu şekle eş yeni
geometrik şekil oluşturulur. Çok kolay.
Sadece bol bol çizeceğiz arkadaş seninle
birlikte. Burada aşağıda düzlemde
verilen beşgen D doğrusu verilmiş. A
şıkkı şunu soruyor. Verilen bilgilere
göre ABC D E beşgeninin D doğrusuna göre
yansıma dönüşümü altındaki görüntüsünü
bularak yukarıdaki düzlemde çiziniz.
Şimdi yansımada ne yapacağız? Kağıdı,
kalemi, her şeyi bırak. Top bende. Beni
izliyorsun dikkatli. Hocam bu şekli
D''ye göre yansıtacağım arkadaş. Bunun
özünde yaptığımız işlemin adı ayna
görüntüsü gibi bir şeydir. Ayna gibi
düşüneceksin. A noktası tek tek
noktaları taşıyacağım, yansıtacağım.
Hocam A noktasındayım. Burası benim
aynam. Hani aynada oluşan görüntüyle
gerçek görüntü arasındaki mesafe
birbirine ne olmak zorunda? Eşit olmak
zorunda. Artık A noktası aynanın öbür
tarafında iç kısmında burada oluşacak
mı? Oluşacak. Bitti. A noktasını
taşıdın. Hatta buraya gel. Biz A üssü
diyelim. Şimdi neyi taşıyalım? E'yi.
Mesela bak. E aynaya 2 birim ya da
yansıdığı noktaya 2 birim uzaklıkta.
Demek ki E üssü noktası burada olmalı.
Hocam geldim. B 2 4 5 birim 2 4 5 birim
uzaklıkta olması gerekiyor. O zaman B
üssü dediğim noktada burada olması
gerekmiyor mu? Aynı şekilde önce D''den
başlayalım. 2 birim uzaklıkta olacak. D
üssü burada. Aynı şekilde 1 2 3 4 5 1 2
3 4 5 al sana D üss pardon C üssü
noktasının yeri de burası. Şimdi bu
noktaları ne yapıyorsun?
Birleştiriyorsun. Tıpkı diğer şekilde
olduğu gibi. Bak A ile E'yi yani A üssü
ile E üssünü birleştirdim. B'ye gitmeden
önce bak önce bir kıvrılıyor ya şöyle
bir tane kıvrılıyor. Evet hocam. Sonra
B'ye kırılıyor. Ama buradaki biraz
eğimli oldu. Onu böyle doğrusal yapayım
ben. Bak B'ye kırıldı. Sonra B ile C'yi
birleştirmişim karşıda. Aynısını burada
C ile D üssünü birleştirmişim. Aynı
şekilde E üssü ile D üssünü
birleştiriyorum. Yeni oluşan şeklim
benim aslında D doğrusuna göre nesidir?
İlk şeklin yansımasıdır. Şimdi ben sana
yansımayla ilgili şunlara bir baktığında
ne görüyorsun? Aslında tuttuğum şekli
birebir o tarafa yansıttım. Yansıttım.
Peki değişen bir şeyler var mı? Burada
özellikle soru olarak gelebilecek
noktalar burası. Her birini burada
cevaplayalım. ABC Dşgeni ile yansıma
dönüşümü altında elde ettiğimiz eş
geometrik şeklin eş geometrik birbirinin
tıpkısının aynısı demek. Verilen
özelliklerinin değişip değişmediğini
tabloda bakınız diyor. Şeklin kenar
uzunlukları değişti mi? Mesela bak B ile
C arasındaki mesafe ile B ile Cssü
arasındaki mesafe değişmedi. CD arası,
Cssü, D üssü hepsi aynı.
A ile B'ye gidiş yolu, A ile B üssüne
gidiş yolu, AE arasındaki mesafe, A üssü
E üssü arasındaki mesafe, her biri aynı.
O zaman bu uzunluklar aynı kaldı
diyeceğiz. Doğru mudur? Yola devam.
Şeklin iç açı ölçüleri. Hocam mesela bak
şurada oluşan açıyla buradaki açı B
üssünun köşesinde oluşan açı aynı mıdır?
Bu C'deki açı ve D''deki açı 90°erece
iken D üssüyile Csündeki açı 90. A'daki
açıyla buradaki A üstündeki açı aynı.
E'deki açıyla E üstündeki açı aynı.
Belki yönleri değişti ama açıların
ölçüleri nasıl kaldı? Aynı kaldı. Şeklin
çevre uzunluğu değişir mi arkadaş? Kenar
uzunluklarının değişmediğini söyledik. O
zaman şeklin çevre uzunluğu değişir mi?
Değişmez. Aynı kalır. Bunlar önemli.
Şeklin alanı değişir mi? Ya açı aynı
kaldı. Çevre uzunluğu aynı kaldı. Kenar
uzunlukları aynı kaldı. O zaman demek ki
alan da değişmeyecektir. Alan da aynı
kalacaktır. Hatta taradığı bölgelere
bakarsan görürsün. Mesela bak 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 tane tam kutu tarıyor. 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 tane tam kutu tarıyor. Burada şöyle
bir tane üçgen. Burada da aynısından
üçgen. Bak burada bir üçgen. Burada bir
üçgen. Burada yarım kare burada yarım
kare. Bitti. Birebir aynı alandan
bahsediyorsun. Şekil ve görüntüsünün
yansıma doğrusuna uzaklıkları
aynı olmak zorundadır. Zaten ayna
görüntüsü yapıyor dedik. Mesela bak bu
şeklin buraya uzaklığı 3 birimse A
üssünün de yine uzaklığı ne oldu? 3
birim. Demek ki de şekillerin yansıma
görüntüsünden sonra yansıma doğrusuna
olan uzaklıkları yine aynı olur, eşit
olur. Bunlar önemli ayrıntılar. Şimdi
örnek 2. Aşağıda verilen geometrik
şekillerin verilen D doğrusuna göre
yansıma dönüşümlerini altındaki
görüntülerini çizin demiş. Burada önemli
aslında nokta şu. Tamam bunları
çizebilirsin belki ama dikkat et yansıma
doğrusuyla arasında mesafe var mı? Var.
Yansıma doğrusunun üstünde bir noktası
var mı? Var. Yansıma doğrusunun üstüne
çizmişiz direkt. Şimdi oluşan şekil
durumlarına bir bakalım. Yine nokta
nokta taşıyacaksın tabii ki. Bak ilk
şuradan başlıyorum. 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4. O
noktanın yeri aslında şurası mıdır?
Burasıdır. Hemen yanına doğru bir nokta
gitmiş miyim? Gitmişim. Sonrasında bu
noktadan aşağı kadar şuraya kadar inmiş
miyim? İnmişim. Şuradayım aslında. Bir
birim böyle gelmişim. Bir birim aynaya
doğru gittim. 1,5tan biraz fazla
yukarıya doğru gittim. Doğrudur hocam.
Şimdi aynaya doğru yaklaştım. Köşeye
gelecek şekilde yaklaştım hocam. Bak
burası. Sonrasında bir bir aynaya doğru
tekrar yaklaştım. Yaklaştım. Sonrasında
bak buradan o 1 buçukluğun biraz önünde
bir yerde biraz daha buçuklu yaparak
durdum. Orası neresi oluyor? Şurası
falan oluyor değil mi? Evet. Şuraya
falan tekabül ediyor. Oradan tekrar
yukarı çıktım. Şuradaki tekli kareye
kadar bir Allah eğri çıktı bizimki.
Şuradaki tekli birime kadar çıktım.
Harika hocam. Bir birim sağa doğru
gittim hocam. Harika. Bak yani bu tarafa
burada sola doğru gidiyor. Öbür tarafta
sağa tersi hareket ediyor. Şuradan düz
doğruyu indirmedik. 1,5'luk düz
doğrumuzu indirelim. Şöyle indirdik.
Sonra da bunu birleştir dedi. Al sana az
önceki K şeklinin yansıma görüntüsü
karşısındaki hali. Anlaştık mı? Var mı
kafalarda bir soru işareti? Güzel. Bu
yansıma doğrusuyla arasında mesafe
olduğunda üstünde olduğunda ne oluyor? N
şekline geldim. Baktın hocam bak aşağı
doğru yani yukarıya doğru 4 birim
çıkmışım. Burada bu noktayı bulmuşum ya.
O noktayı bulabilmek için ne yapıyorum
aslında? 4 birim aşağı doğru iniyorum ve
doğrusunu çizmiş oluyorum mantık
aslında. Mesela buradaki bizim yansıma
doğrusundan 2 birimden biraz fazla 2
birimden biraz fazla çıkıyor. Doğru
mudur? Bak bu şekilde çıktı. Şurada
aşağısı bak birleşiyor zaten bu
ikisinin. Şöyle şunu da yapalım. Tamam.
Bu 1 birim sağa doğru gitti. Bu da 1
birim sağa doğru gitti. Şimdi bak
yansıma doğrusuna doğru yaklaşıyor
mesela. Şöyle ne kadar? Bir kutu. İkinci
kutudan sonra e dur bak mesela zor geldi
orası bana. Dedim ki şuradan gidelim
yine. 1 2 3 4 birim yukarı. 2 4 birim
buraya. Harika. 1 birim yana harika. 2
birimden biraz fazla aşağı. 2 birimden
biraz fazla aşağı. Harika. Bak
şuradayım. Şimdi bu noktayla neyi
birleştiriyorum? Şu tepedeki nokta
aslında bizde nereye tekabül ediyor?
buraya tekabül ediyor. Burayla NR'yi
birleştiriyorum. Burayı birleştiriyorum.
Olayı bitiriyorum. N'nin de yansıma
dönüşümünü çizdik. Dikkat edersen
ikisinin de yine yansıma doğrusuna
uzaklıkları aynı. 0 birim diyebiliriz. D
enteresan. D neden enteresan? Mesela
şimdi önce bu noktanın yansımasını
alacağım. 1 2 1 birazcık fazla. 1 2
birazcık fazla. E bir dakika ya. Ben
yine aynı doğruyu çizdim. Yani bu
doğruyu bak buraya taşıdım. Şimdi bu
doğruyu buraya taşıdım. Aynısı oldu. Bu
yarım daireyi bu yarım daire olarak
yansıttım. Aynısı oldu. Buradaki yarım
daire buradaki yarım dairenin aynısı
olmuş oldu. E bu doğru da aynı. Bir şey
değişmedi. Alttaki doğru da yukarıya
doğru yansıy tarafa geldi. Aslında bu
şekilde ne oldu? Herhangi bir değişiklik
olmadı. Eğer ben bir şeklin simetri
doğrusunu çizer, simetri doğrusuna göre
yansımasını alırsam yine şeklin üstünde
aynı yansımayı elde ederim. Dikkat ettin
mi? Aynı yansıma oldu. Mesela bu nasıl
olabilirdi hocam? Bak ben bir tane kare
çizdim. Bu karenin tam böyle
köşelerinden geçecek karşılıklı
köşegenlerin köşelerinden geçecek
şekilde yansıma doğrusunu çizdim. Bu
doğruya göre şuradaki şeklin ya da
tamamını bu karenin tamamının
yansımasını alacağım. Nasıl alırım
hocam? Bak buradaki üçgeni yansıttım.
Buraya geldi. Sol alttaki üçgeni
yansıttım sağdaki üçgen oldu. Yine aynı
şekli çizdim. Ne zaman aynı şekil tekrar
meydana çıkıyor hocam? birebir hiç
değişmiyor. Yeni bir şey çizmemişsin
gibi oluyor. Ben bir şeklin simetri
doğrusunu çizersem yani öyle bir
noktadan kesiyorum ki birebir iki eşit
parçaya ayırıyorum onu. Oradan kesersem
haliyle ne olmuş oluyor? Yansıma
dönüşümü uyguladığımda yine aynı şekli
elde etmiş oluyorum. Geldim. Sınavda
gelen soru geçen sene böyleydi. Bak
genel sınav yaptılar ya. Analitik
düzlemde birim kare düzlemine
yerleştirilmiş ve üzerine bir geometrik
şekil çizilmiş. Bu geometrik şekle önce
y eksenine göre yansıma dönüşümü
uygulanmış. Daha sonra elde edilen şekle
x eksenine göre yansıma dönüşümü
uygulanmış. Hızlıca elde edelim bakalım.
İlk olarak nereye göre yansıma? Y'ye
göre. En yakın noktadan başladım. Bak bu
noktayı buraya yansıttım. 1 2 3 birim
kaydım. 1 2 3 birim kaydım. Bu
noktadayım. Aslında bu noktanın bu
noktaya göre daha doğrusu doğruya göre y
eksenine göre yansımasını aldım. Şimdi 1
birim y'ye doğru yaklaşıyoruz. Çapraz
yaklaşıyoruz. 1 birim y'ye doğru
çaprazla yaklaştım. Sonra 2 kare
ilerleyecek şekilde y'den uzaklaştım. X
ekseninin üstüne geldim. Bak aynı
yerdeyim. 1 birim aşağı indim. 1 birim
aşağı indim hocam. 2 birim yaklaştım
hocam. Y eksenine yaklaştım hocam.
Buradayım. Kaç birim aşağı indik? 2
birim aşağı indik. 2 birim aşağı indim
hocam. Şimdi ilk çıkış noktamızla
birleştik. İlk çıkış noktamızla
birleştik. Bu kadar. Şimdi bu benim
neyimdir? İlk durumda elde ettiğim
yansıma. y eksenine göre yansımamdır. Bu
bir. Şimdi artık nereye göre yansıma
alacağız? X eksenine göre. Şimdi bak, x
eksenine göre ortak noktalar var. Bir
kısmı da aşağı düşmüş. Önce şurayı
yansıtacağım. Bak yukarıya. Burası
nereye gelir hocam? Bak kırmızıyla
çiziyorum orayı. Burası buraya gelir.
Doğru mu? Şimdi şuradasın. 2 birim böyle
gittin ya. Ya da bak bu noktanın
yansımasını al hocam. Aa buradayım
hocam. Süpersin. Bu noktanın yansımasını
al. 3 birim. 3 birim. Bak buradayım
hocam. Bak noktaları alınca belki daha
kolay gelir. Mesela şurada bir kırılma
noktası var. 2 birim 2 birim şeklinde
ilerleyecek. Nereye geldi? Şu noktaya
geldi hocam. O noktaları birleştirdik
mi? Birleştirdik. Peki bu yine bu en
baştaki yerle birleşiyor mu? Birleşiyor.
Devam ettim. Şuralar birleşiyor mu?
Birleşiyor hocam. Sonrasında burası
nereyle birleşiyor? Şurayla birleşecek.
Buradan da şöyle çekeceğiz.
Aynı şekil oldu mu lan? Bakayım. Aynı
şekil değil mi? Farklı bir şey elde
etmedik değil mi gençlik? Bir bakıyoruz
tekrar. 2 birim oradan indi. Buradan bir
birim indi. Buradan da bir birim indi.
Doğru. Aynı şekli elde ettik. Şimdi elde
ettiğim kırmızı şekil artık bu mu? Evet
hocam. Bu benden ne istiyor? 4.C
bölgedeki şeklin 4 bölgede kalan
kısmının alanı. 4. bölgede kalan kısmın
alanı burası arkadaş. Tamam mı? Bunu
nasıl hesaplayacağız şimdi? Şöyle
hesaplayacağız hocam. Bak ben bunu
parçalara böleceğim. Şurada bir üçgen
görüyor musun? Dik üçgen gördüm. 2 birim
dik kenar şurası 1 birim burası xar 1/ 2
+ aynı üçgenden burada da var mı? Var.
Bak 2'ye 1 e yani 2 x 1/ 2 + şimdi
diyorum ki bak burada yarım bir üçgen
var. Her bir kenarı 1 birim. 1 ile 1'i
çarp 2'ye böl. Üçgenin alan formülünden
ikiye bölme. Artı 1 2 3 tane de tam
kutucuk var mı? Var. Her bir kutunun
alanı ne kadar? Birim kare dediği için 1
kere 1den 1 birim karedir her birinin
alanı. Şu gitti. Şu gitti. Ne kaldı? 1 2
Şuradan 3 daha ne yaptı? 5. 5 + 1/2 ne
yapar? Doğru mu yaptık? Bir dakika. 3 4
5 Güzel. 5 + 1/2'den 2 kere 5 10 11
yapar. 11/2 ya da ne yazarsın? 5,5
birim karelik alan elde ettim. Yazarsın.
Buraya kadar anlaşıldı mı güzel
arkadaşım? Bir problem yok. O zaman gel
yola devam. Harikasın. Harikasın. Şimdi
biz neyi bitirdik? Yansıma dönüşümünü
bitirdik. Şimdi ne var sırada hocam? En
kolaylarından biri öteleme dönüşümüne
geldik. Öteleme ne demek? Bak öteliyorum
seni, iktiriyorum gibi düşünebilirsin.
Düzlemde bir geometrik şeklin belirli
bir uzaklık ve yönde öteleme dönüşümü
altındaki görüntüsü geometrik şekildeki
tüm noktaların istenen verilen yön ve
uzaklıkta ötelenmesiyle elde edilir.
Mesela hemen geldik örnek 4'e. Aşağıda
ABC üçgeni KLMN dörtgeni birimkareli
zemine çizilmiştir. Yukarıda verilen ABC
KLMN geometrik şekilleri ile öteleme
dönüşümleri altındaki görüntülerini
inceleyiniz. Bak öteleme altındaki
görüntüsü bu. Şekillerin hangi doğrultu
ve hangi yönde kaçar birim ötelendiğini
bulunuz. Bunu neye göre belirleyeceğiz
hocam? Her bir noktayı tek tek
inceleyerek. Mesela A noktası 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 birim sağa doğru gelmiş. Gördün mü?
7 birim sağa ötelemişim önce. Sonra ne
yapmışım hocam? 1 2 3 birim aşağı. 3
birim aşağı ötelemişim. Şimdi öteleme
dönüşümünün güzel yanı şu. Bir noktayı
taşıdıktan sonra geri kalan şeklin
aynısını ne yapıyorsun? Çiziyorsun. Ama
aslında onlar da yine aynı ötelemeleri
yapıyor. Mesela C için 7 birim sağa, 3
birim aşağı gitmem lazım. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
1 2 3. Gördün? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3
bitti. Bu kadar.
Şimdi o zaman ben artık birinci şekil
için öteleme doğrultusu nedir? Bak
doğrultu yatayda mı dikeyde mi hareket
etti diyor. Hem yatayda hem dikeyde
hareket etti hocam. Hem yatay hareket
var hem de dikey hareket var. Doğru mu?
Öteleme yönü. Yönümüz nereye doğru oldu?
Yatayda. Yatayda. Yatay doğrultuda
ilerlerken nereye doğru ilerledik? Sağa
doğru hareket oldu. Dikeyde nereye doğru
hareket oldu hocam? Ona bakalım. Dikeyde
de aşağı yönde bir öteleme oldu. Öteleme
miktarı ne kadar? Yukarıda zaten yazdım.
Tekrar yazmıyorum artık. Orada biraz
fazla da küçük yere ayırılmış sağ olsun
dizgicimiz.
KLMN'ye geldik. Şimdi KLMN için yine tek
bir noktadan baz alarak bakıyorum. L
üstündeyim ya da daha öncesi neredeyiz?
Aslında L''deyiz. 1 2 birim yukarı 2
birim yukarı. Burada yukarı ya da sağa
sola ötelemenin önceliği önemli değil. 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 birim ne yapıyorsun? Sola
doğru öteliyorsun. Doğru mudur? Doğru.
Aslında biz ne yapıyoruz? Her bir nokta
için bunu yapıyoruz. 1 2 buradayım. 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 birimde. Hop k üstündeyim. O
zaman ne diyoruz hocam? Hem yatay
öteleme yapıldı hem dikey öteleme
yapıldı. Yatayda nereye doğru gittik
hocam? Sola doğru gittik. Dikeyde nereye
doğru gittik hocam? Yukarı doğru gittik.
Yaptığımız öteleme miktarları burada
yazıyor mu? Yazıyor. 2 birim yukarıya
doğru, 7 birim de sola doğru öteleme
yaptık. Şimdi tıpkı yansıma dönüşümünde
olduğu gibi öteleme yapınca şeklin bir
şeyinde değişim oluyor mu? Bakalım.
Şeklin kenar uzunluklarında bir değişim
var mı? Hocam bak buradaki üçgende BC
arası 1 2 3 4 birimli. 1 2 3 4 birim.
Bak bu AB arası mesafe. Dik üçgenden
kontrol et. 2 2 4e 2 üçgen çizinceki
hipotenüsse
burada da yine 4e 2'deki buradaki dik
üçgenin nesi oldu? Hipotenüsü oldu. Bir
şey değişti mi? Değişmedi. Bunlar ne
oldu? Aynı kaldı. Şeklin iç açı ölçüleri
aynı kaldı. Herhangi bir değişim yok.
Şeklin çevre uzunluğu, kenar uzunlukları
açıları aynıysa çevresi nasıl değişsin?
Alanı nasıl değişsin? Bu da aynı kalır.
Şeklin düzlemdeki yeri. Hah, yeri
değişti zaten. Amaç neydi? Yerini
değiştirmekti ötelemeyle. Şekil
üzerindeki noktalar ve bu noktaların
görüntüleri arasındaki uzaklık
değişmedi. Aynı kaldı. Mesela şekil
üzerindeki noktalara bakalım mı? A üssü
noktası burada, B üssü noktası burada.
Aralarındaki mesafe için 2 4 2 yaptık
ya. Bir dik üçgenin hipotenüsü kadardır
dedik. Hatta göstereyim mi? Buradaki
uzaklığı ne kadar? Şurası 4 birim.
Şurası 2 birim. 4 kere 4 16 2 kere 2 4
topladım 20. Karekökünü aldım hocam. 2√5
birim. Aynı uzaklık burada da var mı?
Var. O zaman öteleme dönüşümü sonrasında
üzerindeki iki nokta arasındaki mesafe
sabit kalıyor mu? Kalıyor hocam. Aynı
kalıyor. Benim de derdim oydu zaten.
Aynı kaldığını da ispatlamış göstermiş
olduk. Şimdi güzel bir soru daha. 5.
soru. Dik koordinat düzleminde 4 - 3
noktası x ekseni boyunca pozitif yönde 4
birim ötelenip Bir dakika şimdi elimizde
ne var? A noktası var. 1e -3. Biz bunu
fonksiyonlarda yapmıştık aslında. Bak ne
yapıyorum hocam? X ekseni boyunca
pozitif yönde 4 birim. X ekseni boyunca
öteleme yapacağım. 4 birim. Pozitif yön
ne demek? Bak şimdi geldik önemli bir
noktaya. Hocam x ekseni boyunca pozitif
yön burasıdır. Bak. Pozitif yön sağa
doğrudur. Negatif yön nedir? Sola
doğrudur. Negatif yön. O zaman biz
nereye doğru gideceğiz? 4 birim pozitif
yön dediği için sağa doğru gideceğiz.
Şimdi bu nokta nerede oluşacak hocam?
Hemen gel bakalım. Koordinat düzlemini
çiziyorum daha iyi anlaman için.
Neredeyiz hocam? 1'e -3'teyiz. Bak 1'e
-3'teyiz. Doğru mu? Tam burada normalde
A noktası. Ben bu A noktasını ne
yapıyorum? X ekseni boyunca yani yatayda
hareket ettiriyorum. 4 birim sağ. 4
birim sağa getirdim. Artık A üssü
noktası burası ki adına B diyecekmişiz.
Y'deki hizası değişir mi? Değişmez. 1in
üstüne 4 birim eklediğinde nereye
gelirsin? 5'e. Aha yeni noktamız B
noktası. 5'e -3 noktasıdır. Hocam
burayla ilgili bir sıkıntımız var mı?
Yok. Şimdi B noktası Y ekseni boyunca
dikeyde hareket edeceğim. Şimdi B
noktasını yazıyorum. 5'e -3. Nasıl
hareket edeceğiz? Y ekseni boyunca
hareket edeceğiz. Nasıl hareket
edeceğiz? 2 birim negatif yön. Yani
negatif yön nereye doğrudur hocam? Sola
doğrudur. 2 birim. O zaman 2 birim sola
götüreceğim. Bak şimdi. N pardon sola
doğru değil. Negatif yön neresidir
hocam? Kafalar karıştı.
Şu negatif yön aşağıya doğru negatif yön
y ekseninde yukarıya doğru olan nedir?
Pozitif yöndür y ekseninde. Burası da
anlaşıldı mı? Anlaşıldı. O zaman diyorum
ki 2 birim negatif yön dediği için
nereye doğru öteliyoruz hocam? Aşağı
doğru öteliyoruz. Şimdi anlaştık mı? 2
birim ötelenecek diyor. Negatif yönde.
Aşağı doğru öteleyeceğiz. C noktası 5'e
-3'teydim. 2 birim daha aşağı indir. Bak
buradaydın. 2 birim daha aşağı indir.
Nereye gelirsin? -5'e. X değerinde
herhangi bir değişim oldu mu? Olmadı.
Artık yeni noktam neresi oldu? Bak
burada oldu. Güzel. Burayla ilgili bir
sıkıntımız var mıdır? Bitti. C
noktasının koordinatları toplamı dolu.
Hocam biri + 5 diğeri -5 topladığımızda
cevap 0 olacaktır. Yola devam. Aşağıda
birim kareli zeminin üzerine çizilmiş
olan dik koordinat düzlemindeki ABCD
dikdörtgeni ve KLM üçgenleri verilmiş.
Çok güzel soru. Zor. Bir hocam bizim
okulda biraz zor soruyorlar dediğinde al
sana güzel soru. Tamam mı? Bu soruya bir
tekrar dön bak isterim. Sınavda
gelebilir bu tarz bir soru. ACD
dikdörtgeni X ekseni doğrultusunda 5
birim sağ, Y ekseni doğrultusunda 1
birim aşağı taşınacak. İkisini birden
uyguluyorum. 1 2 3 4 5 birim sağ
uyguladım. 1 birim aşağı 1 birim aşağı
uyguladım. A noktası burası oldu mu? Bak
sildim bunu.
1 2 3 4 5 bir birim aşağı burada. Oldu
mu? Oldum. Artık nasıl yapacağımı
biliyorum. Şeklin herhangi bir
görüntüsünde değişiklik olacak mı?
Olmayacak. A'nın 3 birim aşağısında D
var. A'nın 3 birim aşağısında kim var
hocam? D var. D''nin 4 birim sağında B
şey var. C var. Bunları da
birleştirdiğimde şeklin aynısı burada
oluşması gerekmiyor mu? Gerekiyor hocam.
Bir kere ABCD dörtgenini ne yaptık? 5
birim sağa, 1 birim aşağı şeklinde
öteledik. Geldim. KLM üçgeni X ekseni
doğrultusunda 1 birim sağa, Y ekseni
doğrultusunda 4 birim yukarı. 1 birim
sağ, 1 2 3 4 birim yukarı. Şuradayım
hocam. K'nin yerini bulduk mu hocam? 1
birim sağ, 1 2 3 4 birim yukarı. L''nin
yerini bulduk mu hocam? Aynı şekilde
artık şekil değişmeyecek biliyoruz.
Birbirlerine olan uzaklıkları,
noktaların değişmeyecek biliyoruz. 4
birim sağa doğru gidebilir miyim? 4
birim sağa doğru gittim mi? K ile L''yi
birleştirdim mi? Süper. Şunları
birleştirdik mi? Süper. Burası da M
noktası oldu mu? Oldu. Şu C'yi şuradan
bir düzelteyim mi? Altına düşsün. Benden
neyi istiyor hocam? Diyor. Bu
görüntülerin diyor ara kesit alanı ne
kadardır diyor. Ara kesit alanından
kastı neresi? İkisinin kesim noktasında
oluşan buradaki üçgenin bana üçgen de
değil yamuk var burada. Bu yamuğun
alanını soruyor. İlla yamuğun alanından
yapmak zorunda değilsin. Nereden
çözeceğiz hocam bunun alanını? Bak
şuradan böldüm hocam. Şurası 1 birim.
Şurası 2 birim olur mu? Alan eş Allah.
Alan eşittir oradan 1 birim. Oradan 2
birim dik kenarları çarp 2'ye böl. + bak
burada bir tane dikdörtgen var. 1'e 2. O
zaman 1 x 2 yazmam yeterli mi? Yeterli.
Şu 2'ler birbirini götürdü mü? Götürdü.
Oradan 1 birim geldi. 2 kere 1'den 2
geldi. Doğru cevap ne oldu? Alan
değerimiz 3 birim karedir dedim. Tam
sınav ayarında. Tam sınav ayarında bir
sorudur bu. İkisinin ortak kesim
noktalarındaki alana dikkat ettin değil
mi? Bak buralar ortak. İçerisini siyah
karaladığım bölgeler ortak. Ara
kesitleri şu bölümü diyor aslında alma
diyor bana zaten. Tamam mı? Şimdi geldik
son bölüme. Dediğim gibi bu koca
bölümden sadece gelirse bir tane soru
gelir. Asıl sorular üçgen benzerlikten
gelecek. Oraya doğru zaten eşlik
benzerliğinden gelecek. Geçeceğiz ama
son bu bu bilgimizi de bir verelim.
Dönme birazcık yoracak bizi. Dönme
dönüşümü nedir? Özellikleri nelerdir?
Kesişen doğrulardan birine göre yansıma
dönüşümü uygulanarak elde edilen
görüntüye diğer doğruya göre tekrar
yansıma dönüşümü uyguladığında dönme
dönüşümü elde edilir. Hoca ne diyor bu?
Bak şimdi elimizde diyelim ki şöyle bir
ABC üçgeni var. Ben de diyorum ki şu
noktaya göre orijin olsun bu nokta bu
noktaya göre dönme dönüşümü yapacağım.
Tamam mı? Bu dönme dönüşümünü yaparken
diyor önce buradaki kesişen doğruların
arasındaki açının iki katı kadar
döndüreceğim. Mesela 90° ben 180°
döndürme yapacağım. Önce diyor 1inci
doğruya göre yansıma dönüşümünü yap.
yansıma dönüşümünü yapınca şöyle bir şey
elde etmeyeceğiz mi? Dikkat et. Elde
edeceğiz. Tekrar kesişen bu doğrulardan
bu sefer alttakine göre yansıma dönüşümü
yapacağım. Bak yansıma dönüşümü
yaptığımda
bu sefer ne oldu? Bak şöyle bir şey elde
ettik.
Aynen hocam. İki defa yansıma dönüşümü
yaparak geldim mi? Geldim. Bu yansıma
dönüşümünde bu doğruları arasındaki
açının iki katı kadar dönme dönüşümü
yapılmış olunur diyor. Şimdi teorik
bilgi bu ama hiç bunu kafaya takma
hocam. Bunu nasıl tutacağız? Aklımızda
ezberleyeceğiz. Ezberlemeyeceğiz.
Sorulardaki sana taktiği anlatacağım.
Şıkır şıkır soruları çözeceğiz. Burada
doğruların kesim noktası dönme merkezi.
Doğrular arasındaki açının ölçünün iki
katı da dönme açısıdır. Bak bu doğrular
açısındaki iki katı kadar döndürdüm
aslında. İki defa yansıma alınca.
Anlaştık mı? Hocam biraz havada kaldı
orası. Gel soruda halledelim o zaman.
Şimdi soru bana diyor ki aşağıda birim
kareli zeminde ABC üçgeni verilmiştir.
ABC üçgeni dönme merkezi sırasıyla ABC
noktaları olmak üzere saat yönünde.
Şimdi önce şunu bir hatırlatayım
aslında. Şimdi saat burası,
saat yönü burasıdır. Saatin dönme
yönünün tersi burasıdır. Biz buna ne?
Evet. Şuna pozitif yön deriz. Saatin
dönme yönünün tersine pozitif yön denir
dönme işleminde. Saatin dönme yönüne ise
negatif yön adı verilir. Önce burada bir
anlaşalım. Şimdi ben nerede
döndürüyorum? Saat yönünde 90°. Saat
yönü neresi? Burası negatif yönde 90°.
Şimdi hangi nokta etrafında
döndürüyoruz? Dönme merkezleri sırasıyla
ABC olsun diyor. Önce A etrafında 90°
döndüreceğim. Dönme merkezi verilen
şeklin üzerinde bir noktaysa o nokta
zaten sabit kalır. A noktasını A'ya göre
90° döndürürsen yine aynı yerde
kalırsın. Şimdi geldim hocam bak B
noktası burada. Bunu ne yapıyorum? 90°
saat yönünde çevireceğiz değil mi? Bak 3
birim uzaklıktaydım 90° çevirdim. Nereye
geldim? B noktasına geldim. Artık benim
B noktam neresi oldu? Burası oldu. Var
mı itiraz? Güzel. Şimdi hocam iyi güzel
yaptın da C noktasını 90 derece
çevirince nerelere geleceğiz? Nasıl
hesaplayalım? Burada da şu taktik var.
Bu taktikle de çözemeyeceğimiz döndürme
sorusu yok. Önce sağa ya da sola doğru
kaç birim gittin onu bul. 1 2 birim
gittim. Aşağı doğru kaç birim gittin? 1
2 3. Bak 2 sağa 3 birim ne yaptım? Aşağı
gittim. Doğru mudur? 3 birim aşağı
gittim. Şimdi bunları yerlerini
değiştir. Nasıl yani hocam?
3 birim sağ, 2 birim aşağı in. Bir
dakika sağ değil artık. Döndürme işlemi
yaptığım için ne tarafa doğru gideceğim?
Buraya doğru. Hangi yöne doğru gittim?
Bak bu yöne doğru gittim. Sola doğru
yapacağım. 1 2 3 birim sola gittim. 1 2
birim aşağı gittim. Artık yeni C
noktamın koordinatı neresi oldu? Burası
oldu. Şuna C üssü, buna B üssü diyelim.
90° A noktasına göre döndürdüğümüzde
oluşan şekil budur. Şimdi aynı şekilde B
noktasına göre 90° çevirmek demek ne
demek? Bak yine geldim. B noktasına
doğru şöyle yeşil A'dan B'ye doğru 90°
çizdim. Saat yönünde çeviriyor. 90° 90°
çevirdiğim için artık neredeyim?
Şuradayım. Bak A üssü noktası burada.
Aynı şekilde B ile C arası burası.
90°erece çevirdiğimde ne oldu? Şurası
oldu. Bu gerçekten kolay oldu. Sonra A
ile C noktasını birleştirdim. Ne yaptık?
B noktasına göre 90° döndürme yaptık.
Aynı şekilde geldim. Mor kalemi aldım.
C'ye göre yapacağım. C ile B arası
burası değil mi? Onu niye eğri çizdi ya?
B ile C arası burası. 90° saat yönünde
çevirdiğimde artık B üssü noktam burası
olur mu? Olur. Şimdi kafana takılan şu
hocam iyi güzel anlatıyorsun da. A
noktasını 90° nasıl çevireceğiz? 1 2
birim sol, 1 2 3 birim yukarı. Tersini
yap. 1 2 3 birim sağ 1 2 birim yukarı.
Artık A üssü noktan da burası olmuş
oldu. Şimdi ne yapmış olduk? C noktasına
göre döndürme işlemimizi bitirmiş olduk.
Her bir noktaya göre döndürme işlemleri
bu şekilde yapılacak.
Şimdi geldik birimkareli zeminde
çizilmiş analitik düzlemde ABCD paralel
kenarları verilmiş. ABCD paralel
kenarının dönme dönüşümü altındaki
görüntüsünü yukarıdaki analık düzlemde
çiziniz. Peki nasıl bir dönme dönüşümü
istiyor? Saat yönünün tersine 180° dön
diyor. Şimdi saat yönü neresiydi? Bu
tarafta. Tersi neresi? Bu taraf. Ki biz
ona pozitif yön adını veriyoruz. Saat
yönünün tersine 180 derece dönmek demek
buradaki açının iki katı kadar diyor. O
zaman önce buna göre yansıma al. Sonra
buna göre yansıma al. Mantıklı ama daha
kolay var. Ama ne gerek var? 1 2 1 2 3
birim yukarı gittik değil mi hocam? O
zaman ben yine 1 2 1 2 3 birim bir
dakika 1 2 sol 1 2 3 birim aşağı gittim
al sana a üssü noktasının yeni yer zaten
dikkat edersen tamına orijinden geçecek
şekilde kaç derece döndürmüş oldum? 180°
döndürmüş oldum. Bak bir daha bakalım. 1
2 birim sağa gidiyordum artık 2 birim
sola gittim. 1 2 3 birim yukarı çıktım
şimdi tersine gittim. 180 derece
döndürme yaparken ne yaptık? Verilen
işlerin tamamının tersini yaptık. 1
birim sağa, 1 birim yukarı gittim. 1
birim sola, 1 birim aşağı gittim. Al
sana D noktasının yeni yeri. D noktasını
da buraya çizdik. D üssü diyelim. Devam
ettik. 1 2 3 4 birim sağa gittim. 1
birim yukarı gittim. 1 2 3 4 birim sola
gittim. 1 birim aşağı gittim. Al C
noktasının yeni yeri. Şurası C noktası.
1 2 3 4 5 birim sağa gittim. 1 2 3 birim
yukarı gittim. 1 2 3 4 5 birim sağa
gittim. 1 2 3 birim aşağı gittim. Şurası
da ne oldu hocam? B noktası oldu. Şimdi
A üssü ile B üssünü birleştirdik.
A üssü ile D üssünü birleştirdik. B üssü
ile C üssünü birleştirdik. Geldik aynı
zamanda C ile D üstünde birleştirdik. Al
sana saat yönünde 180 derece
döndürüldüğünde oluşan şekil. Şeklin
kenar uzunlukları değişti mi? Hayır
hocam. Bak aynı şekli elde ettik değil
mi? Şeklin iç açılı ölçüleri değişti mi?
Hayır değişmedi hocam. Bak aynısını elde
ettik. Şeklin çevre uzunluğu değişti mi?
Hayır. Yine aynısını elde ettik. Şeklin
alanı zaten açılar uzunluklar değişmezse
nasıl alandayız? Şekil üzerindeki
noktalar ve bu noktaların görüntüleri
arasındaki uzaklık değişti mi? Bir
dakika. Şekil üzerindeki noktalar ve bu
noktaların görüntüleri arasındaki
uzaklık ne oldu? Bak aslında orijine
göre yani döndürme yaptığımız noktaya
olan uzaklıkları değişti mi? Hayır
değişmedi. Eğer bunu sormak istiyorsam.
Şimdi bunu da hallettik. Geldim 9.
soruya. Güzel bir soru. Aşağıdaki kareli
zemine yerleştirilmiş analitik düzlemde
alanı 12 birim kare olan bir kare x
eksenine C noktasında, Y eksenine B
noktasında değecek şekilde
yerleştirilmiş. Alanı kaç birim kare? 12
birim kare. Neymiş bu hocam? Bir
kareymiş. Güzel. O zaman bir karenin
alanı nasıl bulunur? Bak mesela şu A
birim. Şu A birim hocam a kare = 12'dir.
Mükemmelsin. Her tarafın karekökünü al.
Bak bu tarafında bu tarafında. A'nın
cevabı √12 çıktı mı? Ya √12 dediğin şey
aslında 2√3 değil mi? O zaman yazıyorum
bak hocam. Burası 2√3 birim. Burası 2√3
birim gibi bunları yazdık. Kareli
zeminde düzlemde 12 C noktasına
yerleştirilmiş. Tamam. Şimdi ne istiyor
bizden? Bu kare B köşesi etrafında saat
yönünde negatif yönde 45° döndürülürse A
üssü noktasının koordinatları toplamını
bulunuz. Şimdi bak, 45° B noktası
etrafında döndüreceğim. Tamam mı? A
üssünün yerini arıyorum. A noktası
burada mı? Burada. Bunu saat yönünde kaç
derece çevireceğim? 45° zaten dikkat
edersen şuraya. Burada oluşan şekil bir
nedir? Karedir. Bu karenin köşegenini
çizdiğinde 45° burada, 45° burada olmaz
mı? Ben bunu 45 derece döndürdüğümde
artık geldiği yer, hadi onu da yeşille
çizmiş olayım. Şuraya falan tekabül eder
mi? Eder hocam. Şurası a üssü uzunluğu
olur. Bana buranın koordinatlarını
soruyor. Tamam mı? Koordinatlarını
bulmaya çalışacağız. Nasıl bulacağız
hocam? Ben sana az önce şunun uzunluğunu
buldun mu? 2√3. Şunu da bulmuş muydum?
Bulmuştum. Burada nasıl bir üçgen var?
Dik üçgen var. Dik üçgende burası BB ise
buranın kenar uzunluğu B√2 olur mu?
Olur. B2 = 2√3'e.
Her tarafı √2'ye bölerim. Tam bir köklü
sayı sorusuna dönüştü. Şunlar gitti.
Güzel soru. √2 ile genişletirim. 2 x kök
içerisinde √2 ile √3'ü çarptım. √6. √2
ile √2'yi çarptım 2. Şunlar sadeleşti. B
uzunluğu ne geldi hocam? √6. Yani
şuranın uzunluğu neymiş? √6. Şuranın
uzunluğu neymiş? √6. Ya da artık oraya
gerek yok. Neden? Biz bunu döndürürken
buraya şu doğruyu aslında döndürmüş
oluyoruz. Haliyle buranın uzunluğu kaç
birim? 2√3 birim. Artık A üssünün
koordinatları belli. X değeri kaç? 0. Y
değeri kaç oldu? √6 birim buradan. 2√3
birim buradan √6 2√3 birim oldu. Benden
A üssü noktasının koordinatları
toplamını istiyor. 06 √6 + 2√3 birim.
Cevap yine √6 + 2√3 birim olarak
bulunur. Sınav ayarında güzel bir
soruydu. 10. soru. Aşağıda analitik
düzlemde verilen klmn dikd dörtgeninin
orijin etrafında 90° saat yönünde. Hemen
döndürelim. Kelm'yi 90° saat yönünde bu
tarafa doğru döndüreceğim. Neredeyim
hocam? Bak şuradayım. 1 birim sağ, 2
birim yukarı yaptım değil mi? Ya bunu 90
derece döndürünce buraya gelmeyecek mi
mantıken? Geldi hocam. N üssü noktası
burası. Bak 2 birim 2 birim sağ 4 birim
yukarı yaptık değil mi? E hocam o zaman
bak bu buraya oluşuyorsa 90° bu tarafa
doğru döndüreceğim. 4e 2 yapmaz mı? Tam
tersi yapar. Şuraya geldi mi? K üssü
noktası gel. Bir dakika bir dakika. Bir
dakika. Doğru yaptık. Tamam. Şimdi
neredeyim? L''deyim hocam. L''ye gitmek
için 1 2 3 birim sağ. 1 2 3 4 birim
yukarı gittim. O zaman ne yapıyorum? 4
birim sağ, 3 birim aşağı gideceğim. Şu
nokta değil midir benim aradığım nokta?
L üssü noktası. Evet. Şimdi M ile M'ye
bakalım. M şurası. 1 2 3 4 5 birim sağ 2
birim yukarıydı. O zaman ne diyorum? 1 2
birim sağ 1 2 3 4 5 birim aşağı indim.
Burası da m üssü noktası oldu mu hocam?
Oldu. Kaç derece çevirdik? 90°.
Noktaları bir sileyim istersen. Şöyle
birleştirelim. Bize gerekli olan bilgi
bir gelsin. Şöyle bir şekil elde ettik
mi? Elde ettik. Şeklimiz bu. Şimdi
geldim A şekline.
Eee, ABCD dörtgeni de saatin dönme
yönünün tersine, saatin dönme yönünün
tersi bu taraftır. Kaç derece? 90 derece
döndürülecek, değil mi? O da nereye
göre? Orijine göre. 90°. Bak, daha önce
buradaydım.
Şuraya doğru gelirsem 45 derece dönmüş
olurum. Bir daha dönersem 90 derece
gelmiş olurum. A üssü noktasını buldum.
A noktası burası. Hocam daha önce
buradaydım. Bir çizelim. D noktasını 1 2
3 4 birim sol 1 2 3 birim sağ yaparak
geliyorduk. O zaman bir aşağı yaparak
geliyorduk. 1 2 3 birim sağ 4 birim
aşağı yaparak geleceğiz. Noktayı
gördüğün için şey yapmıyorum. Tam
şuradan geçiyor. D noktası. Şunları
sildim. A ile D''yi birleştiriyoruz.
Dikkat ed sildik yanlışlıkla. A ile
D''yi birleştiriyoruz dikkat edersen.
Şimdi bak 1 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 2 birim
eskiden sol yapıyordum. Şimdi 2 birim
sağ yapacağım. Daha öncesin pardon 2
birim sağ yapmayacağım. 1 2 3 4 5 birim
aşağı 2 birim sol yapıyordum. Şimdi 1 2
3 4 5 birim sağ 2 birim aşağı yapacağız.
Tersini uyguluyorsun. Şurası B noktası
oldu hocam. Şimdi birleştiriyorum.
Tamamdır. B'yi de elde ettik. C ile D
zaten yan yana. Muhtemelen şuraya
düşecek. Şekilimiz değişmiyor
biliyorsun. Şöyle de birleştirdik mi?
Oluşan şekil bu oldu mu? Bu arada bir
önceki şekli yanlışlıkla silmişim. Şöyle
bir şekil elde ettim hocam. Benden
istenen ne? Kesişim bölgesinin alanı.
Hayda yine saçma sapan bir yerin alanını
arıyor muyuz hocam? Bak şimdi kesişim
bölgesi neresi? Şu bölge kesişim
bölgesi. Ben bu bölgenin alanını
arıyorum arkadaş. Buranın alanını nasıl
bulacağız? Şurada yarım üçgen görüyor
musun? Görüyorsun. Birim kareydi. 1 x 1/
2 + şurada 2'ye 1 üçgen görüyor musun? 1
birim 2 birim. Dik kenarları 1 x 2/ 2 +
şu bölge ne kadar birim? 1 birim kare
aldım bunu. 1/2 şuradan 1 geldi. 1 1
daha 2 + 1/2 cevap ne geldi? 5/2 geldi.
Biliyorum çok zevkli bir bölüm değil ama
sonuna geldik. Sen hemen bunları
yapıyorsun, hallediyorsun, bitiriyorsun
ödevlendirmeleri. Sonrasında asıl
mevzuya geçiyorsun. O anlattığımız
bölümden sadece bir soru gelecek arkadaş
ama illa dersen oluşan bir soru avcısını
daha ihtiyaç var falan. Onu da veririz.
Fakat önemli olan noktanın eşlik
benzerlik olduğunu hatırlatırım. Kendine
iyi bak. Videoyu beğenmeyi, yorum atmayı
unutma. 9. sınıflar her daim
yanınızdayım. Unutmayın. Hoş kalın.
Hoşça kalın.
oho
[müzik]